hello my name is cynthia rhodey
and i'm an associate research fellow at
psizer
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about non-clinical covid19 vaccine
development
during a pandemic
i'm going to start off with a brief
background on coronaviruses
and then touch on the target antigen for
most covid19 vaccines that are in
development today
i'll then move on to discuss general
safety considerations for
infectious disease vaccines in general
coded 19 vaccines
and mrna vaccines
then i'll share with you a brief review
of the traditional route of infectious
to vaccines
development and contrast that with a new
paradigm for development
that we have pursued underneath the
coca-19 pandemic
and finally i'll close with some lessons
learned
bronoviruses are a large family of
rna-based viruses that infect birds and
mammals
their envelope single-strand viruses
with one of the largest nucleocapsids
among the rna viruses
the name coronavirus or corona
specifically
meaning crown or halo comes from the
crown-like spikes that cover the surface
of the coronavirus
these viruses primarily cause upper
respiratory
and gastrointestinal disease and this
disease can occur
in many species including
feline infectious peritonitis or fip and
cats
and transmissible gastroenteritis in
pigs
the coronavirus which you're probably
familiar with the structure
the envelope consists of four major
structural proteins
and the little red spikes that are you
can see on the surface
are the spike glycoprotein that mediates
viral entry into the cell
in humans there are four coronaviruses
that are associated with the common cold
two alpha and two beta and more recently
three beta coronaviruses have emerged
that can potentially cause severe
respiratory syndromes in humans
these include sars severe severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus
which emerged in 2002
middle eastern respiratory syndrome
coronavirus
which emerged in 2012 and
the virus that we're dealing with today
sars kobe 2
which emerged in china in 2019
among the coronaviruses
despite protein glycoprotein binds to
a variety of receptors
in particular for the human cyrus kobe
co coronavirus the original as well as
sars kobe
ii the spike protein of these viruses
bind to the angiotensin converting
enzyme 2 or h2
this slide shows an image of the spy
protein
in more detail it is a trimeric
protein that consists of three main
subunits
excuse me i'm going to go back and um
with the small um
receptor binding domain or rbd
pointing down and binding to the blue
ace2
receptor on the host cell service
it is only one of these receptor binding
domains
they fluctuate in the up and down
position and
when in the prefusion conformation
the spike protein only has one of these
three
receptor binding domains that is in the
up position
now i'm going to transition to telling
you a little bit more
about general considerations for safety
evaluation
of infectious disease vaccines the
toxicology
assessment of these types of vaccines is
intended to evaluate the safety of both
the vaccine components as well as the
associated
immune response off-target or severe
expected toxicity
is generally not accepted as these
vaccines may be administered to millions
or even billions of healthy healthy
people
although exceptions may be made based on
the risk benefits
profile
there are a number of major regulatory
guidelines for infectious disease
vaccines
and i've listed a few of them here but
there may also be regional and
disease-specific guidances to consult
in general as infectious disease
vaccines
are most likely targeting a foreign
antigen
that should not be cross-reactive with
any antigens
present in humans non-clinical safety
studies
that are performed for these types of
vaccines are generally
smaller are generally smaller intact in
number
than for a typical small molecule or
biologic
in general a repeat dose toxicity
in a single species is sufficient
and then depending on the target
population a developmental
and reproductive toxicity or dart study
may also be conducted in a single
species
finally depending on the specific
vaccine modality
and if you're using any novel adjuvants
or excipients in the vaccine
other non-clinical safety related
studies may be conducted
such as biodistribution neurovirulence
etc
some viral infections as well as
vaccinations
and this includes for in regards to
viral infections things like flabby
viruses
measles or even respiratory synthesial
virus
can illustrate neutralizing as well as
non-neutralizing
enhancing or non-enhancing antibodies
if more non-neutralizing or
sub-neutralizing antibodies are
generated
that do not clear or block the infection
then antibody dependent enhancement or
ade
can occur occasionally non-neutralizing
antibodies
and or complement components bind to the
virus
in the case of a viral infection and
promote phagocytic
cellular entry via the fc gamma
or complement receptors
examples of this have been reported with
dengue fever which is a flavia virus
but have also been seen with feline
coronavirus
and feline coronavirus vaccines in cats
with fip
and inconsistently in some animal models
the hamster and rhesus macaque of
sars coronavirus thus ede
is a theoretical safety concern when
developing a vaccine
for sars kobe 2.
another point to consider when thinking
about ade
is that enhanced disease may also be
driven by the generation
of the th2 rather than a th1 response
to the vaccine antigen
so what is the risk of ade with vaccines
targeting sars cody2 it appeared that
the risk
was low based on several factors first
expectations were that covid19 vaccines
would produce high neutralizing antibody
titers
and low levels of non-neutralizing
antibodies
as more code 19 cases occurred there has
been no
evidence so far of enhanced disease
after cyroscob2 infection and
re-exposure
or treatment with convalescent plasma
and coronavirus enhanced disease has so
far
only been demonstrated as i mentioned
before with the feline coronavirus
which is an alpha coronavirus while sars
cov2
is a beta coronavirus
however while the likelihood was low
it is still a potential risk and
monitoring for ade
was still warranted so non-clinical
efficacy models
have been used to assess the potential
for ade
and in addition clinical trials included
mechanisms to identify
signs of ade to date there hasn't been
any reported
in addition vaccine clinical trials have
shown a strong th1
rather than a th2 response
now let's talk a bit about a vaccine
modality
that i've become very familiar with the
mrna-based vaccine
how do these vaccines work the mrna
encoding the antigen of choice in this
case despite
a glycoprotein locked into a prefusion
conformation
is encapsulated into a lipid
nanoparticle or lnp
the lipid nanoparticle increases the
half-life of the mrna compared to
induction of naked mrna and also
works to increase cellular uptake
once the lnp is taken up by the host
cell
it travels through the endosomal
pathways and eventually releases
its contents the rna into the size fall
the mrna is then translated and the
protein antigen
is expressed depending on the signals
contained within the rna and the express
protein
the protein itself may be expressed on
the cell surface
or the protein may be processed by the
proteasome
and peptide fragments presented via the
major histocompatibility complexes or
mhc
this slide lists some of the safety
considerations for an
mrna lnp vaccine first
mrna is non-infectious and
non-integrating
it is degraded shortly after engineering
the cell
but can stimulate dna immune system via
toll-like receptors such as
trl tlr7
mrna can be modified to contain
modified nucleosides many of which are
naturally occurring such as
pseudo-uridine
which work to dampen that innate immune
response
finally where does the rna go and where
is the protein expressed
this is driven by the lnp which acts as
the delivery device for the rna
lnps generally consists of structural
lipids
such as cholesterol and phospholipids in
ionizable lipid
the complexes with the mrna and a
pegulated lipid to allow for better
stability in half-life
of course if any of the components of
the lnp
now the lipids are used safety and
anatomy assessment
will likely need to be conducted
this figure shows the traditional
approach to infectious vaccine
development and as you can see
that can take many years sequential
investments are made along the way
as more confidence is gained in the
vaccine safety
profile and efficacy this approach was
obviously not going to work to stem the
world wide spread of sarcoid ii
and its associated disease to the
dentine
in the u.s the first step to changing
the approach to vaccine development
occurred with the deluxe declaration of
a public health emergency
related to covid19 which occurred in in
february of last year
this allows the option to authorize use
of unapproved products
the criteria for granting an emergency
use authorization
includes the disease must be serious or
life-threatening
the vaccine or treatment must show
evidence of efficacy
the risk benefit analysis must favor the
use of the vaccine or treatment
and there should be no adequate approved
or available alternative
in addition to the eua a precedent for a
rapid approach to vaccine development
during a public health emergency was
established by the who
in 2018 when evaluating the potential
ebola vaccines
this approach emphasized the use of
platform data
which could be used alone or with
supporting
interim in life data to enter phase 1
clinical trials
while the who focused on viral
vector-based vaccines
i've expanded the potential definition
of a platform as follows
a platform is a modality in which
components are comparable
with the exception of the antigen itself
so that would mean the same adjuvant
excipient the same dna viral vector
or plasmid or rna platform
as well as the same delivery device
later guidances issued by the fda
specifically on coca-19 vaccines
which are included here on the slide
also supported
the use of platform data as a way to
accelerate development
in 2020 other global guidances and
initiatives supported rapid covet 19
vaccine development including
a workshop by the international
coalition of medicine's
regulatory authorities that supported
use of platform data
to allow for rapid entry into the
clinical into clinical trials
and from the who outlining a pathway
from
an emergency use listing for coding 19
vaccines
as an example of how this approach was
used
and in particular for our pfizer beyond
tech
coca-19 vaccine bnt-162b2 or community
this slide shows the non-clinical safety
related studies that were supplied to
health authorities to support the ind
or cta compared with the data that was
supplied to support the eua
or maa for the ind and cta
we leverage rna platform non-clinical
and clinical data
from candidate vaccines targeting other
indications
in addition to interim dosing phase data
from an ongoing repeat dose toxicity
study
with a number of coded 19 vaccine
candidates
this was supplemented with some protein
expression
biodistribution data for the eua
and maa we provided final results from
repeat dose toxicity studies that have
been conducted
timing of the dart study results in the
situation of the eua or in the case of
the maa
an audited draft report from that dart
study
in addition data from an nhp
immunization and challenge study
which was our non-clinical assessment
for enhanced
enhanced disease which was provided
protein and lnp biodistribution data
as well as a small admin package for the
novel lipids that we use
in our lnp
although we were able to utilize an
accelerated approach
i must emphasize that there were no
compromises made
to the safety evaluation of the vaccine
non-clinical safety data including
platform data
and immunogenicity data was provided to
health authorities
prior to entry into the clinic
many of the activities were performed in
parallel
on an accelerated path versus sequential
the more traditional paths that i
discussed or discussed earlier
and these included non-clinical clinical
and manufacturing
activities as well as others
as well as we engaged in constant
communication
with regulatory authorities on the
timing of delivery of non-clinical and
clinical data to support
filings as well as ongoing activities
this slide showing a snapshot of the new
york times copied 19 vaccine tracker
illustrates how far we've come with
approximately 10 vaccines already
authorized or approved in various
countries around the world
and some or more close to it giving us
the tools
to tackle the current coded 19 pandemic
in summary what i learned from my
experience helping to develop
a covid19 vaccine during the ongoing
pandemic is that early and frequent
interactions
with health authorities was critical
platform data can support clinical trial
initiation
and this data may be supplemented with
interim data
for less well-characterized platforms
any safety data from
candidate vaccines or related vaccines
in humans
may be relevant and finally it also
leads me to wonder
if there are any other areas where we
can use these lessons
such as for severely debilitating and
life-threatening indications
my final slide acknowledges only a few
of the other pfizer and biontech
colleagues that were involved in the
non-clinical development of bnt 162b2
as it's always a team effort thank you
very much